Scott Eastwood is opening up - GQ  Australia about the last time he cried  revealing his former girlfriend  tragically died quote I dated a girl a  couple of years ago who died in a car  accident the tough thing is it was a  fender bender and there was a recall on  airbags her airbag exploded it shot a  projectile through her body it split her  spine and uhm I've never told anybody  that the 30 year old actor says the  tragedy may have made it harder for him  to date Eastwood also admits he's never  called the girl's father quote I still  haven't found the right words as far as  his dating life Eastwood was linked to  supermodel Adriana Lima last month after  they were spotted looking flirty in New  York City but a source close to the  suicide squad star previously told et  they're not an item